[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir à partir de
dorénavant comme l'ont dit les fumeurs
sont priés d'écraser leurs mégots à la
veille du jour des morts les amateurs de
cigarettes et de pivot devoir faire leur
deuil de leur vie ce favori c'est en
effet aujourd'hui que le décret 92 478
interdisant de fumer dans les lieux à
usage collectif est entrée en vigueur
la guerre de la nicotine est elle pour
autant déclarer en quête de pascal tous
ces bons et jean baptiste rivoire
oui bonjour monsieur je voudrais vous
avez une table pour 4 ce soir à 20
heures
et voilà on a un petit problème c'est
qu'on ait deux fumeurs et de non fumeurs
et que les fumeurs veulent absolument
fumée comment est d'accord mais les
non-fumeurs super pas les cigarettes
comment on va faire et les non fumeurs
bon apparemment les restaurants aux
presque tout prévu mais qu'en est il de
la ratp et des usagers du métro parisien
ce journaliste se ruinent la santé pour
vous informer en une heure ce matin la
station étoile malgré une provocation
évidente dans une zone d'interdiction
absolue
personne n'a rien dit nous avons
rencontré des usagers plutôt
compréhensifs
je crois qu'il existe la liberté la
naissance
si je continue alors autres lieux
publics
cet après midi dans un café du boulevard
saint germain ce monsieur visiblement
gêné par les bouffées consciencieuse et
héroïque du journaliste il ne fera
aucune remarque
même réaction pour ces jeunes gens qui
vont subir la tabagie pendant plus d'un
quart d'heure je peux vous poser une
question
tout à l'heure j'ai fumé dans la figure
nous réagissait pas
nous sommes jamais résultat un
provocateur bredouille et malades et des
parisiens plus que tolérant bien sûr ce
reportage n'avait rien d'un sondage
l'échantillon d'aujourd'hui n'étaient
pas représentatifs
mais apparemment malgré la loi les
fumeurs ou encore de beaux jours devant
eux
[Musique]